Film Courage: How do I make my
characters more than just a caricature?
Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: In early
drafts we're again putting paint to the canvas and
they'll be caricatures and they'll be cliché. I
talk to my students a lot where they're like “Oh
I'm so worried this feels cliché or fabricated.”
I'm like “Don't worry it is cliché and fabricated
but keep massaging it.” Even then when you're
working on conflict we are fabricating conflict
with the…we're storytellers so we have to take
the normal conflict of everyday life and smash it
together to make it interesting because I mean if
let's say I'm a character through my life and my
driving on the Los Angeles freeways, that might
be a story (a very boring story) but then again
maybe there's something in that where there could
be a film from the point of view of a guy driving
Los Angeles freeways and with that is when we
go to the craft and keep going “Hey that's a
really dumb idea and feel free to take that dumb
idea” but it's something where “Oh wait okay,
this character can do this, this character
can can go there,” it's showing up to the
page every day that's that's the main
thing just show up, show up, show up.
Film Courage: What's your process of
incorporating supporting characters
predetermined or added as you go?
Tony: For me it's added as I go I will I write
the especially in first drafts I'm writing the
characters I'm writing the story about as fast
as my hand can write and then and then all of a
sudden something will show up and a character
shows up and something interesting go oh wow
that's interesting and then it's just characters
start to take play start to start to find their
way in and then some characters stay in and some
characters leave so the character kind of has to
prove themselves and other times characters may
sound the same so you can smash three characters
into one character so I add as I go but they're
either or because predetermined is someone who
would work from an outline and kind of come
with the strug they they can come with the
whole family tree of characters before writing
a single word and so that's where writers when
they just kind of understand their process and
understanding their process is just continuing
to show up to the page every day then going oh
wait I like the family tree of characters or I
like my friends call me a pantser because I do
things by the seat of my pants so I just like
to I just like to throw paint and then try to
make it pretty later by coming back to it day
after day which may not be the quickest way
to get work done but it's just the way that I
personally do it so you so learning your process
is the way to go and have you written supporting
characters and then said you know what I think
this one has to go oh yeah oh yeah no there's
I kill a lot of darlings and yeah I've had to
kill a lot of darlings over this last year and
in that in the novel that I now have finished
but oh great yeah but the yeah it hurts you're
like oh man but it's sometimes they upstage the
the journey or they upstage as a protagonist and
it's all about serving the story serve serve
your protagonist but by creating that conflict
that stays within the within the world that you've
created what's the first thing you would do if you
were beginning to write characters for a series
that's a really good one because a Series has to
carry Seasons so when you're when you're thinking
about characters you're also thinking about World
building a lot more and thinking about okay I
can write the pilot and also when I'm pitching
I have to know Season 1 Arc season 2 Arc season
3 Arc or if you're writing a sitcom you have to
know the world of where they have the what do you
call it the enclosed story of each episode like a
procedural too a lot of procedurals have their
enclosed stories and it's just like and we wrap
up oh boy we got him this time but wait till next
week when we are not sure if we'll get him so yeah
it's if you're beginning to write characters for
series play with play with the beauty of the form
of the series what's what's the series about the
series has to have series has to have a tone unto
itself that last for a very long time and then
that at that point you can say a feature film is
almost a short story and a series is a novel or
series of novels and that's when the world of is
the world of is important in a film too but really
have fun with the world of where you're putting
them even a even a TV show like friends or like
Seinfeld you're putting Seinfeld on his little in
his apartment a lot and Friends they're all in
the cafe they all have their conflicts and for
for a lot of TV series they are they are tied in
the sets that are created so I guess on that note
think about keeping your locations as minimal
as possible how do you keep your locations as
minimal as possible so if you're working on a film
I mean if you're working on a TV series they can
shoot as much as possible on a sound stage before
having to go out and do all the exteriors in your
opinion which character traits make Colonel
Jessup A Few Good Men such a polarizing and
unforgettable villain I just watched it filmed
this last year and assigned it to my students
oh that great yeah it's it's his moral code is so
stringent and his status is always high well talk
about status play that court scene is one of the
most beautiful Court scenes to watch in the very
end where I think it's an 8 minute scene where
it's just like watching status shift from Colonel
Jessup to the Tom Cruz's character back and forth
that's just a lot of status shifting but the what
what Colonel Jessup has as a as a trait that is
very positive in humans is he has an insatiable
drive to do everything he can that he feels is
right to protect everybody and even though it's
utterly flawed from his from our point of view it
is not flawed from his point of view and it's just
I feel like that it's there's just something about
it and it's just Jack Nicholson I think reading
Colonel Jessup on the page and then watching
Jack Nicholson be Colonel Jessup just so great.
Film Courage: Here we go, Amelia Films what
makes a character memorable especially villains?
Tony: I like that question. Sometimes the villain
needs to be more interesting than the protagonist
because the more the protagonist goes through
their journey and the more interesting the
villain is the more the protagonist has to go
through the obstacles of this interesting and
powerful villain so even though the the villain
is the antagonist they are the protagonist of
their story so yeah Batman is such Batman's such
a great example of that because Batman yeah okay
he's kind of interesting but the villains are
always more interesting than Batman is as far
as the TV series I don't know what the other stuff
is no I'm kidding but it's but things like Batman
and Spider-Man they they hold the center of the
story and then those villains just make those
villains pop give them the weirdest quirks in the
world give them you don't even need to write well
I feel like you need to write the backstory
of everything and write just and know your
character inside and out but when you're putting
it to script or you're putting it to a novel you
don't need to have that all in there you just
write them from knowing what their background
is from knowing why they are so messed up in the
head and have this twisted angle on life and it's
the villains are beautiful so just make sure that
and kind of make them lovable too I mean you I if
you're working on a character for say a couple
years you really got to like you almost have to
love your character even if they're the jerks of
the film you have to understand and have empathy
because in order to order to write and keep the
process going we have to love our characters if
we're not coming to the mour and writing with
love that's kind of a sad place to be I mean
come come with self-destructive hate and go
how am I going to do this this is never going
to work but at the same time when it comes to our
characters we love them because we want to take
them on the most interesting journey that we can
put them through right and do you think we like
characters that are more self-destructive rather
than those that are destructive toward others
because maybe we can relate or yeah yeah we can
relate and it's yeah I think you're right the the
self-destructive ones I feel like I mean I really
hope everyone has some self sabotaging things they
do to themselves because I'm the king of it so I
immediately relate to that whereas people who have
out I think so I think I that's a good that's a
good thought because as viewers that's easier to
connect with us when people are out when outright
pushing out and hurting other people most of us
don't do that and even when we're at our worst
we won't hurt someone else we or I like enclose
and be really upset but sure but it goes in it
doesn't go out if it goes out too much there
might be a sociopath type level thing which is
fun to watch so much fun to watch not fun to be.